jack you're a 20-year vet a sniper navy
seal you've written new york times
bestsellers you have a lot of
experiences that's the one thing that
hasn't changed since the beginning of
time is that primal nature of combat
things have evolved technology wise it's
really comes down to you putting another
human in the ground and that part has
not changed for me there's no possible
way that as a combat leader i would be
able to treat a female exactly the same
as i would one of the guys for whatever
reason i programmed to protect females
that's how i was raised i think it's
just innate in us as humans to protect
those who are going to carry on and make
sure that our bloodlines and our species
continue to move forward
[Music]
so if you feel like you have a pretty
accomplished resume my guest today
served 20 years in the in the navy seal
as a navy seal he was an enlisted sniper
then he was a supervisor for snipers
then after he went and saved the world
as a navy seal he decides to come out
and write books he doesn't just write
any books every book he's ever written
has been a new york times bestseller and
one of them just became the number
number one new york times bestseller and
that is jack carr jack thank you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment oh
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to talk to you for a couple of
selfish reasons because i'm taking notes
as we go just seeing how uh how you've
done well you've built what you have
built um over the years here it's so so
impressive and uh and i sincerely
appreciate you having me on why i
appreciate that i was looking at your
stuff i'm like this guy i mean you know
from one side to the other side you know
most people
end up making it to the top and maybe
one space but for you to do it in two
space that's pretty impressive so let's
let's get right into it jack
at what point did you know you wanted to
be a navy seal and if you can kind of
walk us through you becoming a navy seal
and what that was like
yeah so i mean very early on so i'm one
of those people that knew what i wanted
to do from a very early age and i think
a lot of that has to do with my
grandfather being killed in world war ii
so i never obviously grew up with him
and i grew up with
medals from his squadron he was a
corsair pilot and for those that
remember there was a show in the late
70s early 80s called black sheep
squadron with robert conrad where they
had pappy boynton's black sheep squadron
out in the pacific with the corsair that
had the wings that would fall off the
gold wings like that and that that's my
grandfather flew so i had his medals i
had pictures of his squadron i had his
uh his wings uh and i just grew up
knowing that i was going to follow his
footsteps into the military i didn't
quite know what yet but i knew military
was my path and then i found out about
seals and once again this is the
an example of the power of popular
culture that i found out about seals
through a movie through an old black and
white film called the frogman and the
only reason i got to watch the frogmen
is because i got to flip the channel on
and for those that grew up in the 70s
you remember that you were the tv
got a dad on remote
couch like you had to run up you had
four channels you had abc nbc cbs you
know that one outlier channel those were
those are the four and during the
commercials for uh football on sundays i
got to run up and turn that channel to
that outlier channel because they were
always playing a world war ii type of
movie and i got to watch it for two
minutes and my dad would watch on his
watch and after two minutes flip it back
back to football and we'd watch football
until the next commercial but one of
those showed these guys swimming up over
the beach and putting explosives on
obstacles in the advance of a
conventional force landing and i asked
my dad hey who are these guys and he
said those are frogmen that was the name
of the movie yeah and i said what are
frogmen these guys look amazing and he
said go ask your mother and i was also
very lucky because my mom was a
librarian so we got to go down to the
local library and start researching so
she took every opportunity she could to
take us to the library and teach us
about researching and just get us into
books we grew up surrounded by books and
a love of reading so
early 80s you could read almost
everything about special operations most
of it focused on vietnam back then but
uh there were there were a couple there
was like a couple magazine articles a
book here and there but there wasn't
much in the early 80s mid 80s in the 90s
it started to get a lot more than in the
2000s obviously after september 11th all
that information exploded in the
internet you could you could spend the
rest of your life
researching and not doing that's the
part where you have to find that find
that line where you prepare enough to
then take that step and do it
um you didn't have any choice yeah jack
let me ask you when when you were going
in so for example for me when i went
into the army i was like okay here's
what my recruiter said it was going to
be this is exactly what he said it was
going to be i was not expecting this
what was it for you when he became a
navy civil year said i was expecting
navy seal to be this that's exactly what
it was but i had no idea about these
three things man i wish they would have
told me about this or this is pretty
cool to experience these three things
what were some of those things that you
experienced as a seal
yeah i was pretty lucky uh in that i did
all that research ahead of time so i
didn't show up
i wasn't surprised by how hard buds was
i mean i'd known since i was a little
kid that 80 of people are going to quit
that was part of the draw towards going
there is because it is
touted as one of the toughest regiments
ever devised by a modern military so
that was the draw for me so so i didn't
show up and i wasn't shocked that i was
going to be cold wet tired and hungry
they were going to make me stay up for a
week during hell week like none of these
things came as a as a shock to me and
i've been preparing for for quite some
time but that shock i think it was
really a shock it was just kind of uh
is walking across the quarter deck at my
first seal team and most of the
experience of my peers was this was
similar and that we all thought we were
going to get issued the pager we were
going to get issued all this amazing
gear where the pedro is going to go off
in the middle of the night we're going
to fly off and do the save the princess
off save the world and then fly back in
time here's the next night and that was
not how it was in the late 90s
they handed you a broom as a guy and
they said hey go sweep that go paint
that wall change that light bulb take
out the track you did new guy type stuff
and there was nothing really going on in
the world
so but you had to be prepared that was
your job is to be prepared to go to war
and then after september 11th then it
became what we thought it was going to
be when we first got to our seal teams
and then from september 11th all the way
through today
it became exactly what we thought was
going out there and executing the
mission for the country what was how
about how about when you went to war how
about when you went and you got deployed
what was exactly what you expected it to
be what was different
interesting question so i the the relief
of because you've trained so much and
you've prepared so much for this but you
really don't know until you go out there
and do it if you're going to perform um
so that little part that little megan
question in the back your head
and i didn't anticipate what it would
feel like to go out and do those first
missions what that would what that would
feel like internally i know i would go
out do the mechanics of it but it was
this sense of relief that i have been
tested in combat and i was not found
wanting i did not let the guys down to
my right and left and that was this
feeling of relief for me anyway i don't
really know for uh for anybody else but
i had this sense of relief like okay it
wasn't just training it wasn't just
something i aspired to i have now done
it and now i'm building on this
foundation adding experience to that
training and then i continue to add that
experience continue to learn from both
mistakes and failures going forward so
it's uh it's all about adapting as you
know both in in life
and on the battlefield no matter what
you're doing but uh but that was that
was the sense of relief i think that was
most surprising to me did you have any
shock factor was there any shock factor
to you where you know like uh let's uh
uh a pitcher okay pitcher a place for
high school then maybe goes and plays a
triple-a and then hey he gets called up
are you gonna come and pitch first game
is gonna be
in st louis cardinals you know you come
out oh my gosh 60 000 people and then
you get up there and you're looking at
the guy you know mike trouts up and
whoever's up you know it's the different
leagues and you're like okay i gotta
pitch this guy the booing you know maybe
the the speed you know they say from
college football to nfl speed
everything's faster what was what was
the shock factor for you was there
anything when you got deployed where you
said
nobody prepared me for this was there
anything
i think the confusion of how hard it was
to tell
where the enemy is where the bullets are
coming from where the mortars are coming
from where the rpgs are coming in from
in the chaos of combat in particular uh
the campaign for ninjaf which was a
two-week campaign in iraq to retake the
city from the jaish almighty militia in
august of 2004 and it was just chaos and
it was like what i had seen on those
world war ii movies i watched with my
dad uh where just there's bullets flying
everywhere it's an urban environment and
uh you're kind of not really sure you're
hearing these tracks and you're and
you're just not sure exactly where's
what's what's going on because you're
getting these bradleys by these fighting
vehicles and they move around these
tracked vehicles so you're kind of
discombobulated uh things are exploding
everywhere you're moving in and in the
back drops down and you run out into the
fight and uh it's kind of like getting
your bearings is a little bit uh
discombobulating i guess
one scene you know the opening scene up
saving private rhine where they open it
up and
did you have an experience like that
when he went out there where it was
sudden
i think that that experience of the
bradley fighting vehicle having that
ramp go down in the middle of a
firefight he's dropping you off because
you don't really know you're not
as a sniper in the backers assault team
leader in the back you're not really in
communication with uh with the guys that
are driving and even if you were you
wouldn't be exactly sure it looked like
the map study that you did and all of a
sudden boom you're out there and it's
time to go so that would be the most
similar but i don't think it's anything
yeah could ever be like with those guys
experienced uh going over the beaches at
normandy that's just a whole another
level i mean you're going in to a place
where the enemy is entrenched the enemy
has uh the high ground they have they
have pretty much all the advantages and
you're running across open space to try
to get up to that high ground when they
have machine guns in place up there
that's that's back when it was hard
yeah i remember the first time i watched
that movie i get to the unit it's i
don't even know when uh saving private
ryan came out so i get to 101st airborne
september of 97 saving private ryan
let's see when it came out it's a couple
years later probably 2000 or something
98 there you go that makes sense so we
got to the unit couple months later they
said
there's a movie coming out that's about
your unit that you guys going to get a
chance to see it before anybody else
sees it so we went in we sit down in
this theater with 600 other soldiers
we're watching this movie
it's called saving private ryan it's
about your unit you're going to be so
proud and at the beginning we're just
watching at the end 600 soldiers and
tears fired up so
proud to be representing a unit like
that saying hey you know i'm proud to be
here very emotional when you see a movie
like that what a great job they did
hangs all those guys just one of the
best movies i've seen of all time but
did you ever you ever seen a movie fury
with brad pitt no i keep meaning to see
it i need to see that movie so there is
this one scene jack it's a sick have you
seen that scene in have you seen a movie
fury with brad pitt have you seen it
where there's this one scene where they
go out
and he's in the tank
and they're getting shot up and one of
the soldiers
cannot handle it he just cannot handle
it he's panicking he's frozen he's
locked up he doesn't know what to do he
starts peeing in his pants and they have
the scene it's a very good scene to show
that some people when it hits you all of
a sudden you don't know how you're going
to react your first time and you know
brad pitt's trying to kind of calm the
guy down and say hey it's going to be
all right go through it
was there ever a moment like that you
saw one of your peers that was tough
behind
you know enemy lines but then the moment
they crossed enemy lines that pressure
just kind of exposed some of the fears
that we may have
not really i didn't experience that but
if you stopped and took notice uh you
could see how some people didn't really
fight to stay in the front line units i
guess that's a better way and good for
them i mean if they knew beforehand that
they were in the wrong line of work or
maybe they were more uh suited to the
administrative side of the house or
something like that yeah um and they
went to places where they were less
likely to find themselves in iraq and
afghanistan i guess but that would be
the closest thing i can think of um just
because that training that we go through
is is so intense especially after people
started coming back from iraq and
afghanistan and incorporate those
lessons into the training um then for
sure it wasn't a surprise what you were
coming in to do uh so so i never really
experienced somebody having that type of
a
reaction downrange um but i'm sure i'm
sure it happened but i just never
experienced that yeah i i if so for us
we we flew from la to uh atlanta and
then we got in the greyhound and then we
it was like five of us from l.a and we
drove to south carolina fort jackson and
we're driving everybody's tough because
everyone's from a gang and everyone's
you know this guy's from 18th street
that guy's from this this guy so we're
all bragging about who's tougher and
then you get to the unit and drill
sergeants come up and they start
hollering at you and you're like okay
i'm not used to this you know what your
girl is doing right now she's with your
best friend hollering his name she ain't
even thinking about you right now she's
already over you know just mentally
messing with you yeah and then it got to
one of the tests where you have to give
the other guy ivs
okay and it's like it's not a big test i
mean to you probably ib is not a big
deal it's just you know you're just
putting an iv in your body so we're all
sitting there like 100 of us
and one guy does the next guy does the
next guy does it five people refuse to
do it a couple of the guys do it they
knock out they pass that they can't
handle deal with needles uh uh it was
interesting seeing it you know as you're
going through the process
of how some of the things you were
prepared to go through some of the
things you were not prepared to go
through but again in your world that's a
completely different level you're a navy
seal you guys are seeing stuff that only
a few people get a chance to see so uh
out of curiosity for us we had a very uh
uh initiating type of an environment
where people were initiating new rookies
that were coming here
the hazing concept which was very normal
back in the days nowadays you know the
smallest joke you tell them you may get
the ets team knife dishonorably
discharged from the navy because you did
the wrong thing was the hazing thing
going on back then when you were in
because it was for us definitely
yeah no it was and uh you know i can see
how it could get out of hand at some
some levels or some places but for me it
was very positive experience i mean i
look back on those those times with my
new guys with our e5 mafia uh all
together there and going through that
that hazing and for whatever reason the
platoon that i was in as a new guy they
did a a great job with it and of course
the part you look forward to the hazing
you look forward to is getting your
trident and pounding that thing into
your chest uh that's the one you look
forward to you hear about it happening
to other people that's what you want to
have happen now it's probably illegal
now you go to jail if you do it probably
but uh
i mean that was like that's the right of
passage is your hopeful tune coming by
and what i remember is that the guys
that were huge that i thought were going
to hit so hard yeah they didn't hit his
heart but like like the guys i thought
were gonna be like
they hit so hard and i distinctly
remember that and they put you up
against the comics box there's no give
and they just bam bam pound that thing
and everybody cycles through in the
whole team and it was fantastic
today is there still a mark till today
no the pins are so small i mean once
they go in it's mostly uh
impact you know once you hit like
something because it is big you know it
is it is the trend is huge so it's just
those little pins are small they go in
and you know that's fine it's like
getting your ear pierced probably or
something like that especially when
you're all yoked up from doing thousands
of push-ups and pull-ups and buds so
there's a little a little more padding
back a little more armor back then in
the day
do you think some of the stuff that
happens uh
with the military to toughen uh them up
do you think it's not because you know
some people talk to you say well the
method of war has changed so much that
all of those things that rah-rah you
know toughen people up it's not
necessary today you know because today
it's more about you know maybe a gentler
approach to toughen soldiers up we don't
need to do that anymore today it's more
of a cyber warfare today it's more about
not necessarily getting up there on the
front enemy lines you know you need to
toughen soldiers up in a different way
or do you believe no we still need to
train our soldiers to be tough because
the enemy is training their soldiers to
be tougher than us
what is your uh
thoughts on that
oh yeah did you see that uh the video
went around a few months ago that showed
the uh russian airborne commercial
comparing it to ours
oh my goodness yeah well yeah that
should that should tell everybody
everything they need to know there um
and the part of adapting looking at what
you do on the battlefield we have 20
years of data right now uh incorporating
those aspects into our training uh very
smart but the other side is that uh
when we're talking about adaptability
that cyber warfare piece yeah maybe
those guys don't need to be doing what
we're doing at seals because they're
fighting a different battle space
they're right here just like i have no
idea how to fight in that space unless
they said
go to difficult location and destroy
said physical location like that's where
i excel uh but getting in there and the
different levels of the internet and i'm
doing all this research for my my new
novel that's coming out next year and
i'm looking at the cyber warfare piece
and the quantum computing piece and the
levels of the internet and where these
future battles might be fought well they
might be fought there but there's also
that chance of an electromagnetic pulse
that shuts that stuff down and here we
are we're back to fighting so fighting
oh there's always that primal that's the
one thing that hasn't changed since the
beginning of time is that primal nature
of combat that uh that visceral uh
man-to-man person to person in the
trenches that part has stayed fairly
much i mean as things have evolved
technology wise you still it still
becomes a person against another trying
to kill one another that part has stayed
the same so you have to keep up with the
technology keep up with the tactic
techniques procedures keep learning
about your enemy so you can better
counter that enemy so you can better
translate if you're a leader some of the
uh directives coming down from higher
authority so you can get the job done uh
there at the tactical level but it's
really comes down to you putting another
human in the ground and that part has
not changed do you think we're tougher
today with our training than we were 20
years ago or
if we're not what's the consequence of
the direction we're going today
yeah uh so i yeah i got out right before
all that stuff started to change um so i
think by the time i got out in 2016 we
were doing a very good job of
incorporating lessons learned from
downrange a lot of the medical stuff had
evolved quite a bit
over the years because we just had so
much learning
so much we learned so much just on the
ground in the in the battle space
so that part we were doing a good job of
incorporating that into the pipeline
into the training
but when you let off the gas a little
bit to take a take a breath which is
fine to find to do just to make sure
you're on the on the right path but then
if you want to just become more
inclusive because of uh some sort of an
equity of outcome type of uh that that's
going in the wrong direction uh i think
and that will be uh our downfall and
we're interested in that last book that
i wrote i put myself in the enemy's
shoes so i spent about a year and a half
looking at the united states through the
eyes of iran
of russia of north korea of china and
what was terrifying to me is that by the
time i got done with that
year writing that book looking at us
from the enemy's side
my i had to make some adjustments to my
novel because i thought you know what if
i was the enemy we're doing a pretty
good job of destroying ourselves from
the inside right now and i could just
take back if i'm china russia there's no
need to rush uh if i'm those countries i
can take a step back take a breath and i
can just watch us do what we're doing to
ourselves from the inside this discord
that is perpetuated by a lot of the
social media type of algorithms
that work for advertising well guess
what yeah they also work for political
parties uh and they work for uh
galvanizing your base and getting
support and raising money and that that
sort of a thing so
it was it was disheartening i guess uh
to say the least that if i was the enemy
i might just watch us for a little bit
um because we're doing a lot of their
jobs for them unfortunately so so you
know the oath of enlistment right when
you you and i did that it's hey i
patrick david do solemnly swear that i
will support and defend the constitution
of the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
and that i will obey the orders of the
president of the united states and the
orders of the officers are pointed over
me according to regulations a uniform
code of military justice so so help me
god right
so okay this is in uh a title 10 u.s
court act of fifth of may of 1960
replacing awarding first adopted in 1789
with amendment effective 5th october of
1962. okay so
foreign or domestic right
what do we do
if the enemy
to protect the constitution is domestic
and it has to do with the officers above
you
so what what is the right protocol
if the people that are domestic it says
in the constitution protected all
enemies foreign or domestic what if it's
domestic and it's your superiors how do
you handle that
that's the real question and uh that's
one that i am
i guess glad is the wrong word but that
i'm watching from the sidelines and i'm
exploring pages of my novels because uh
it allows me time to think about it to
process to to do exactly what you just
just said
and try to figure that out the best i
can because now there's no doubt there
are segments of our society that want to
destroy that very thing that you're
bearing true faith and allegiance to
that constitution that uh that
guarantees natural rights or if you're a
god-fearing person uh uh rights from god
either way natural or god-given uh that
inherent right to self-defense uh the
right to keep and bear arms that is that
that is is something that if you were
just to appear here out of nowhere with
no background and then all of a sudden
you just you just appeared on earth and
someone tried to kill you it would be
very natural thing to defend that gift
of life and uh as as a husband father uh
the citizen that's my responsibility is
to defend that gift for me for my family
for my community
and that's a very natural thing yet
there are elements of our society that
want to remove that right enshrined in
the constitution uh now the first
amendment the first amendment used to be
something growing up in the 80s that we
could all get gather around we could say
hey no matter what i disagree with what
you're saying but i will die for your
right to say it that was what made us
americans and now we're talking about
limiting free speech we're shutting down
free speech wherever we possibly can if
it doesn't support a certain ideology
it's a very interesting time in these
next 10 years especially as it pertains
to the first amendment are going to be
extremely telling you know what i'm
asking you here's why i'm asking you
because you know to have written all the
books that you've written you must have
done a ton of research right i mean you
like your time out right now you got you
know a deadline to hit and sometimes you
feel
uh god created kids for you to miss
deadlines you know it's it's uh you know
uh which i i understand but
when you do all this research and you we
got what 1776 till today that's our
history right it's not a lot it's 2 45
give or take whatever we got about to be
246 245 years of history
how many times have we had it to the
point in the last 245 years where the
people
that are becoming enemies some of them
are domestic and they're your superiors
and if we've had that in our history
how have we as the people won that
fight that battle
that is the one thing that gives me hope
i try to be very hopeful in my outward
projection um but uh internally and when
i sit down with my wife on the couch at
the end of the day and we have a glass
of wine together and discuss things um i
mean we it
sometimes that conversation is not as
hopeful as uh as what i project well one
of the things that does give me hope is
thinking back to that civil war period
and that post-civil war period and what
was done to to try to bring the country
together and how grant did that um
those parts of our history do give me
give me hope um because it was tough
back then
but today
it's yeah we have this new thing and
this new thing is these social platforms
is everybody has this voice and everyone
can be manipulated also by these
different platforms um and it's just
that part is what was missing back then
by trying to think hey what if we had
social media back then what if you had
an instagram at tickstock a facebook
a linkedin you had youtube you had uh a
couple companies controlling a lot of
that information what would that civil
war period post civil war period have
looked like with that element and and i
don't know the answer to that obviously
because they didn't exist back then but
uh but that's the that's the outlier
that is is a lot different from other
times in our history in that time that
i'm talking about that gives me a little
hope for going forward well they didn't
have to deal with some of those things
today these multinational type
corporations where the wealth is uh is
up there at a very at the very top and
there's a lot of control involved in
data and information it's not just about
money anymore it's about data and
information and controlling that
information and using it to control a
populist
and there's no doubt that you can
control how someone is thinking based
off what you feed them on these channels
so it's a different environment and it's
a it's a scary environment for our kids
to grow up in i think because it's
completely uncharted territory and uh so
i think about that quite a bit well i
mean it would you say gas lighting is a
new thing you think propaganda is our
new thing
they've been on for a while right both
of them gas lighting and propaganda it's
not a new thing but
what is the biggest difference with it
today versus but we've had civil war
before we've all read the story or seen
the movie north and south right you know
what happened where
you know
we can go to history books and go
through them but
how much different is it
versus today you'll have a debate with
somebody and they'll say look the way uh
the the the government is set up you
know our system is set up with judicial
executive legislative you know it is set
up in such a way that you are protected
this can't ever be lost this can't ever
be you don't even have to worry about a
enemy domestically
bringing america down do you agree with
that
well up until about 20 years ago you
still had to operate in a way that was
very similar how you would have to
operate in say 1865 let's say meaning
that if you wanted to control or
manipulate you would have to
buy a journalist you would have to
blackmail a journalist you would have to
blackmail a politician by a politician
um in the traditional sense of actually
purchasing these people or getting
information on these people to use to
blackmail them so
so and a lot of you companies did that
companies planted stories they paid
reporters to do things um now that's so
those things still existed that
propaganda that manipulation all that
still existed but you didn't have as
many tools to use and now you have so
many two different tools to use a lot of
them are much more subliminal than uh
sending someone outside of a uh
reporter's house to to you know to catch
him leaving with someone who wasn't his
wife or whatever it might be to use his
blackmail
now you have all this data that is and
every keystroke is
its record i mean there's a lot of data
out there on all of us and it's
controlled by a very few very few people
at the very top that's a lot of power
that's a lot of power to have so uh so
that propaganda manipulation all that
was around but the tools were different
back then those tools that were existed
back then still do exist but now there's
a lot more out there to use so it's it's
a once again it's adapting to that
battle space as you're writing and your
creative imagination is coming up with
stories what what what what is your
creative imagination thinking about to
get somebody to flip or let's just say a
person for the longest time has been a
you know abiding citizen card carrying
loving american patriot capitalist you
know constitution protector and all of a
sudden they flip
you know what what is the strategy to
get somebody to flip is it shame is it
uh information on what they did against
their wife that they don't want to be
public because their legacy is going to
be tainted is it something that they
again i'm asking purely from your
creative side what are some methods you
would add to say here's a proud citizen
that loves america all of a sudden he
starts giving in to china all of a
sudden he starts making
you know
certain compromises because there's
something behind him
what would your creative imagination say
here's five ways to get somebody to flip
yeah so all those traditional ones still
certainly exist um
they're just being more ways to uh to
get where you want to go
with those but what's even more
dangerous i think today is something is
a moral vanity where you don't even know
that you have been quote unquote flipped
but that you are willing to destroy the
bedrock of a nation that gave you all
the options and opportunities all these
from the inception of this country up
until today all these people
died to give you the freedom of choice
to be able to make your own decisions
not have it dictated to you by a
monarchy um by a a federal government
that was going to put you in a certain
category no you can break out wherever
you appear uh on this on this planet in
this country uh you have the option an
opportunity to make your own decisions
going forward to build the life you want
to make the life you want now we have
this moral vanity that has slipped in
that allows us and a lot of us at these
highest levels that have been afforded
all this opportunity that allowed us to
build great
wealth um and
now we want to undermine that for the
next generation coming up because of
this moral vanity so that we can make
it's going to these these cocktail
parties so that you could you you're on
the same page as uh good morning america
in the morning or uh msnbc in the
evenings or whoever you watch and you
feel good about it because this peer
group that is uh
larger than it would have been in the
past because of quote-unquote friends on
social channels and followings and all
the rest of it make you
empower you to feel this moral vanity
that makes you want to undercut what
exactly what allowed you to
create the life that you wanted so it's
a it's an it's an amazing thing and
psychologists are going to have a field
day with it's uh today and looking back
on it because you're destroying the very
foundation of the thing that allowed you
to succeed
uh jack you're you're a 20-year vet a
sniper an enlisted sniper navy seal
you've been all over you've been
deployed everywhere you've written new
york times bestsellers
you're a citizen that takes care of your
family father married
uh and you have a lot of experiences at
the same time you know the conversations
you have with your wife at night with
your family with your peers now that you
write these books you're going to be in
different circles so you're having
conversations that are high level type
of conversations
who do you trust the least today
if you were to say who you trust the
least today
who would that be organization or
individual
yeah organization and it's it's uh
it's the military i mean sorry it's uh
it's the media
but it's interesting that we're walking
in to this big tech and this meeting as
media big government l ambush so you
remember your day is the l ambush and it
means you're walking here in the middle
and you have enemy here and here so if
they fire they get you they don't hit
each other so that's what we have we
have big tech big government but we've
lost so much trust in these institutions
that we all used to trust as citizens uh
and that that journalists
the media we used to trust them when you
see these uh
see the new york times coming in let's
say 1975 or you see the washington post
in the time frame 85 84 or 86 you
trusted you trusted them and today you
think i'm going to be manipulated by
these by these same organizations um
they have an agenda they're they're
supporting a certain party they are
supporting a certain ideology uh they
are undermining undermining another
ideology they are undermining the exact
amendment that first amendment that
allows them to do what they do
you have journalists you have other
authors you have people in that space
calling for
more restrictions on the first amendment
which to me is i mean i can't believe it
as a kid that that grew up before that
uh that that became now acceptable um
and then that part is just uh yeah it's
just heartening to me as a citizen so if
i have to pick one it's an institution
it's not a person it's that it's the
media it's something we used to trust
okay so you have that legacy trust
especially from older people but uh
today
it's uh how do we play games
let's play game i like playing games uh
and and maybe we can we can play a game
together i'll give you
uh uh an organization and you tell me
zero to ten what your trust score would
be okay instead of doing a speed round
we're gonna do a uh uh
organization you tell us what you're are
you a sports guy or no are you not okay
i'm not my sports is uh international
relations i guess and staying up to date
because none of this is sport so this is
fantastic wonderful all right so let's
start zero to ten uh do you trust uh
the general of army navy air force
marines that they have the best interest
for america zero to ten
i'm gonna put that at a six or seven
okay cool all right how about mainstream
media
zero no [ __ ] okay how about president of
the united states
that's a tough one because
it's fairly obvious we're dealing with
something that we haven't really dealt
with before which is cognitive decline
in a you know head of state
in this country but uh so i'm gonna go
ahead and put that at a
uh
two or three okay how about china
and i only had two or three it only gets
two or three because i still have a
little bit of a hope left in me uh
that's actually
i hope to be a positive looking person
that's the only reason it gets that what
an optimistic guy you are man that was
just fantastic how about china zero to
ten
oh zero okay how about the um you know
the major virtual governments i'm
talking twitter for you know today
dorsey sign you know uh resigned and the
new guy took over he's gonna also get
off the board himself
how about trust in virtual governments
facebook youtube google twitter all
those guys
i'm gonna say a one and the only reason
i give it one is because it had they
they had potential they had potential to
uh to have that sort of trust that uh
that we had in established media back
50 years ago 100 years ago um but it
doesn't exist anymore do you think they
can still change do you think it can
change i think it's too big of a machine
okay
okay uh how about the the top 10 richest
men and women in america i'm talking
bezos you know you talk uh elon musk all
those guys top ten
do you trust me uh i'd have to look at
the list because it does shift so i'm
gonna go with the with a five uh there
because
i know some of those guys in that in
that top ten list um and i i trust them
implicitly um but uh but some of the
others uh and then some of the ones that
i don't know that i've just met in
pasting that uh that i don't
um
yeah so it's it's so i'm gonna give it a
five just because that list does does
change how about the one a lot of those
people are self-made i mean look at some
of these questions
how about if i give specifics bezos musk
buffett
uh gates
uh and and let's stay at that those four
names yeah musk and
on buffet on the positive side the other
two probably on the other okay still
it's just still puts me on five so puts
me at 50 50. jack how about the
wonderful journalists that we have in
america
yeah there are so few actual journalists
um you have to really seek out
people that are doing that job like a
glenn greenwald or you have to seek out
those people that are after the truth no
matter where
it falls without trying to manipulate
that data or write things in a certain
way so that it supports their ideology
and their personal agenda so you really
have to do the homework on quote unquote
journalists because there are so few
these days that are doing it in the
in the tradition that we think of as
journalists in this country going out
after the truth um exposing the truth uh
holding
uh
leaders feet to the fire exposing
corruption speaking truth to power those
things are in short supply these days
how about a fouchy
i just can't yeah let's just put that at
a
let's put that at a one because of the
hope factor
did you see him on face the nation today
did you did you see him didn't i saw a
couple of the headlines but i i did not
dive in yet i mean if you want to have a
motivating day about 2022 watch it it
will inspire you it's it's a very really
it's a very uh sarcastically very
optimistic is is the direction i'm going
with it uh
yeah you know it's uh it's
i've never seen him this arrogant in an
interview than the one i saw today was a
very little bit weird on how it was you
know typically
he takes a very neutral position
uh and he'll still go you know you will
know what side he leans towards but
today was uh
if if you don't if these politicians
question somebody like me who's a
scientist i'm the guy that represents
science and we know what we're doing and
here's what we're going to be doing it
was just very concerning on the way he
took the approach you know on uh uh the
angle he took question for you from the
data side so you know how uh we've all
seen the data when china puts out the
data and they say our unemployment rate
in china right now is two percent like
wow
what an amazing and noble job they're
doing to keep the unemployment only
right
and
i feel bad for the people that believe
that it's only two percent uh uh with
one and a half billion people living
there and some of the stuff that
leaks out sometimes
when it comes down to data
in america and the data that's put out
to
us how much of the data do you trust and
who do you trust it from like you know
for example what the reason why i'm
asking this question from you is
um
if you and i were to go buy a house
today
and you want to buy a million dollar
house whatever you want to put 200 000
down
the bank is going to say
yeah no problem let's run a credit score
okay and they go to experian you know
transunion equifax your score comes up
7 38.
you're fine you've had one late in the
last three years and you fixed it
because it was a car payment you had a
wrong checking account you're good we'll
finance you for this million dollars 20
now you're good to go great so they have
a source to go to verify your
credibility right
where do we go to verify the credibility
of the people that are giving us the
data
that's it we can't that's why that's why
we're we don't have this trust this this
trust has been eroded
so much between big tech and the citizen
between big government and the citizen
and each opportunity that both big tech
big government media has
to build some trust they do the opposite
they continue to
to use their platforms their data to
support a certain ideology
that marginalizes
almost half the country and continues to
divide the country which does what well
it
galvanizes basis for politicians it gets
more clicks on things for social media
gets more advertisers in front but you
know that's just the base level that's
just the base level stuff that's fine
that makes them
extremely wealthy
but what it really does is give them
data and gives them information on how
to future it to manipulate in the future
not just to make you uh you know buy a
set of steak knives but to
get you to vote a certain way um to get
you to think a certain way that is where
we've lost all this trust and that's
really the power that these uh tech
giants have and going back to that let's
go back to the military part real quick
because i don't want to say six or seven
trust in the military and uh when we
look at that exit from afghanistan
though that we had 20 years to prepare
for that moment
20 years uh we had 20 years of our own
experience we could have gone back to
the soviet experience there 10 years
from 79 to 89 we could have gone back to
three british incursions in the 1800s
and 17 and early 1900s uh we didn't have
to go back to alexander the great we
didn't have go behalf to go back to
genghis khan we had our own we could
have just took any one of those years
that we have been in afghanistan let's
say from march of 2002 let's say let's
let's give us a few months where we had
the culminating point of victory uh in
those early days that we went past uh
culminating point of victory and turned
that success into failure um so we had
all those years to prepare and we rushed
to failure we ran to failure and uh and
we have civilian control of the military
but uh but we also have a military that
had 20 years to prepare for this as well
for these contingencies and it didn't
come as a shock
to me or to most uh people that i know
that it ended the way it did so uh
that's that trust in military that took
a hit right there you have a company
that has 20 years to prepare for
something they know except it's coming
they know exactly what what's happening
and they screw it up that bad they could
have done it worse had they been
actively trying to do it the worst job
that they possibly could so i'm lowering
my score from the military i'll go back
to three or four how much of that credit
how much of that responsibility goes on
the leaders of the different branches
that we have versus the president
i mean we know commander-in-chief is
president biden that's who it is today
right that's who the commander chief is
but how much of it is
the general the army navy marines air
force saying no no guys we can't do this
this is not the right approach and and
the meaning you know where because
you're in meetings where sometimes maybe
you're reporting to somebody that's
above you you're superior and you got to
say
boss i'm telling you we have to take a
different route this is not going to
work out well for us let's reconsider
this how much of it is them not giving
enough pushback rather than just saying
okay let's just go ahead and do this
costing us 83 billion dollars of
equipment we left behind to the taliban
oh yeah it's a lot i mean it's easy for
the military to say uh politicians lost
the war you know it's very common thing
to say uh in vietnam after vietnam um
but uh we can see
general after general after general
going in front of congress from 2001 all
the way up to just a few months ago
saying the exact same things we are
making progress just need a little more
time a little more funding more troops
and that's not a president telling them
to say that that is them going in front
of congress and giving their honest
quote unquote honest assessment
to congressional leadership and to the
american people and by default to their
troops who are watching them give these
speeches and give this testimony
and you can pick out anytime 2004 2008
2012. you can pick out it sounds exactly
the same they all sound they say the
exact same thing if you could go back
and pick out how many times they said we
are making progress i just need more
troops more funding more resources they
all said that and the one guy who didn't
uh and i don't want to say his name
because i'm gonna mess it up um but it
was like 2009 let's say but it was
somewhere right in the middle and he's
the one guy he raised some questions
well guess what he was replaced a few
months later and that hadn't happened
since uh macarthur in korea and he did
that because he raised concerns about
how much progress we were actually
making and that's what happens and that
sent a message to the rest of our flag
level officers hey this is what happens
when you tell the truth this is what
happens when you give your actual honest
assessment you're not around much longer
and off you go to pasture um so that was
probably one of the most devastating
things that happened over the last 20
years is senior level leaders to see
what happened to the one person who said
the truth and he got fired yeah but i
think uh i think even with that man i
think we
i think if 20 people get fired no one
got fired
you know what i'm saying if one person
got fired yeah one person got fired but
if 50 people get fired america cannot
afford to have 50 people to fire i don't
know if that makes sense or not so you
know a a uh
you're running a company and you know
you got uh your name is ford
and 50 of your employees come to you and
they say look we can't work 66 hours a
week and these kind of conditions you
got to give us a retirement plan you got
to give us health insurance you got to
give us a bit of a raise this is just
not going to work out right ford can't
say ah whatever guys go ahead we're
going to keep doing no you can't afford
to do that right but if one person does
that and two people do that a small
percentage complain fine you're always
going to have that and you're never
going to please everybody i think i
think if more people would have stood up
the hell are you going to save the four
people to four general the army marines
air force navy is all on the same page
saying president this is a terrible idea
we're not doing this it's just a
terrible idea
uh uh who are you gonna fire all four of
them i mean that's just a catastrophic
situation there anyways you you you
question the backbone
and again look i'm not in that position
for me to put all the responsibility on
them i don't know where it is to put the
responsibility on them i know what it is
to have lived in iran for 10 years and a
decision carter made on the human rights
hoping to
you know
help out iran with the 3 000 political
prisoners under the shah or
the you know political refugees or you
know the muriel both live in cuba next
thing you know it backfired on america
and it backfired on iran and we know
what happened with iraq half a million
people got killed because of a bad
decision we don't yet know the
repercussions of the decisions that we
made we may not even see the side
effects of this for the next five to ten
years
that's why i wonder like how do you not
just look at your leader and say this is
a bad idea
we're going to be united on this against
you i don't know um you ever you ever
been in a meeting yourself where your
leader told you what to do and you guys
your peers sat there and said this is a
bad idea i'm not asking for names you
ever had how many instances like that
did you have to tell the person you
report to this is not a good idea
usually they're coming down from above
that person and they're parroting
something that comes above even higher
but i was at such a low i was a low
tactical level um so i didn't have those
sort of strategic level level meetings
so they were more like why is this
person just parroting what has been uh
this person is useless they're just
saying what's coming down the pike here
i didn't need them to sit in that seat
and just pair it um what we need to do
is figure out how to make this work uh
make this new policy this new directive
this new guidance uh whatever it might
be now we have to do the uh the on the
ground boots on the ground problem
solvers aggressive problem solvers and
maybe turn a good idea around uh and
and make it work for us and and then be
able to explain it to the guys that are
gonna be even one level below us um uh
in a way that makes sense um
because if you lose that trust if you
just pair it what comes down the pike uh
the e5 on the couch
waiting in the platoon space he he
noticed
they def they know and you lose that
trust and everything you do in the
military or in life i think is an
opportunity to build trust both up and
down the chain of command side to side
with your peers um and you have to take
advantage of it what we're doing in this
country right now is we're
losing trust at every opportunity it
seems which is uh yeah once again just
disheartening
yeah i i um
what what percentage of the guys that
executed the plan on leaving afghanistan
knew was a bad idea what would you say
you would have guessed it's an odds game
i'm not telling you know the answer
what would you say the percentage of the
leaders that executed what was told
what they were ordered to do knew it was
a bad idea
i would have to say 99 or i agree with
you
i agree with you so kent and 99 say
guys what the what are we doing you know
i'm saying this shit's not gonna work
like
that's what we trust them to do like
when you're looking up that chain of
command yeah uh their responsibility
like if we mess up down here at the
tactical level we're gonna be held
accountable for sure if you make a
mistake up here no accountability you
retire you go sit on the boards of one
of these companies that has defense
industry type of ties
[Music]
exactly so to see to so to see them not
stand up to that plan and why it's so
frustrating to everyone is because once
again carl and joshua's put on war he
said that the most important attribute
of a leader of a military leader is
common sense that's why the person with
zero military experience has never read
a book on the military can look at
afghanistan and just take a take five
minutes and look at it
and see what a bad idea it is to give up
our group hey why give up a tactically
advantageous position and put your
troops in a tactically disadvantageous
position that doesn't make sense oh
great you know why because that person
who's never had any military experience
or read a book on strategy or
international relations or any or
tactics can look at it with that eye
with that common sense and say this does
not make sense um and yet our senior
military leaders uh you know stood by
and did almost nothing as from the
outside looking at it i'm not in there
anymore obviously so
but
that's what it looks like from the
outside and what we saw happen at abby
gate uh when we saw those
uh all those deaths and a lot more
people that are that are wounded that we
don't even hear about um
that's the result jack i got two other
questions for you before we wrap up one
of them is
uh uh
you know when you're
like i interviewed the former director
of uh mossad him and i were sitting down
i think shabbat was his name i'm trying
to see what his name was really
interesting guy we had a conversation
together
and i said hey you know
you guys haven't been around that long
who trained you he says nobody trained
us said okay
who did you train well we trained some
of our enemies but we don't train them
on everything i said okay
but when i was in iran you would hear
about savage
and they would say who trained savage
well the cia trained savage who else
trained savage mi6 trained savage okay
cool
and then you go and see china
china's intelligence right now is
maybe the best and no one's even
recognizing them you know they're top
two top three but nobody knows how
they're training themselves right so
the question i would have for you is
when it comes down to us training our
allies
what is the protocol that we follow in
training our allies where you don't
train them too much
to know everything you know that one day
they won't flip on you
like what's been happening lately with
some countries that used to be allies
now their enemies
that's right even before september 11th
this was a conversation that we had uh
because we did jsteads we did training
exercises around the world with partner
nations with host nation forces and we
always say hey let's be a little bit
careful this is us this is the e4 z5s
e6's chiefs these are the people here
that are on the ground doing it that's
not coming from above it's not saying
hey don't make sure you don't teach this
this this
it's us on the ground having that common
sense again saying
but it's tough also when you're doing
combat foreign internal defense meaning
you're going out there into the streets
of ramadi with a partner force uh or
you're in afghanistan you're training up
a partner force and you're going out and
executing these missions
because your life the lives of your guys
to the right and left are they're right
there depending on this host nation
force so you do want them to be as
trained up as you as they possibly can
be but now look what's happened all that
training all that uh
this is afghanistan as as i'm sure sure
you know it's very natural thing to
change sides why not go to the strongest
warlord side that makes sense if not
guess what's happening to me in my
family we're going to get skinned alive
and hung from this tree uh so we're
going to go over to that side so it's a
very natural thing loyalty is a little
bit different over there um so now they
have all these weapons all this
technology uh all this training and for
even people that fought on our side uh
some are now on the other side because
that makes sense now that keeps them and
their families alive that's the that's
the the tactical choice that they're
that they're making and it's part of the
culture and that's something we didn't
really understand going in we totally
failed to understand the nature of the
conflict to which we were committing
forces we had this imperial hubris
that's uh allowed us to go in and say
hey we're the united states of america
we had initial successes and then we
thought oh we got this let's shift focus
to iraq um osama bin laden escapes into
pakistan and uh we start nation building
anyway you could point to all these
different uh
missteps from that point on but from
december 2001 uh we handled that
situation very poorly but our senior
level leaders it's their responsibility
to understand the nature of the conflict
to which they're engaging u.s committing
u.s forces and they failed to do that
and they had 20 years to learn and they
failed over that entire 20-year period
um so so yeah i do
i do look at them with a critical eye
but i guess the good part today is that
it gives me a lot of a lot of material
to work with in the novels
yeah that's a that's a a part of it
where
i sometimes wonder i'm like i understand
training your your own self with people
that are going to be with us long term
where you're again domestic or uh you
know
um foreign or domestic you know you want
to train the people that are here but
sometimes we feel we're building our
enemies even bigger we're experienced
now with china right now everything we
do with capitalism china duplicated now
china's
everybody's relying so much on china
with the chips with everything that
they're doing that we have no choice we
strengthen our enemy
now they're bullying us and we are the
leaders of the free world it's a little
bit of a weird situation there but last
question here i had mike ritlin on mike
ritland i'm sure you know michael lenez
he was on with us on the podcast we had
a great time and the conversation came
about during that time they were talking
about women in navy seal
he gave his opinion on women on navy
seal and but recently i i don't know if
you saw bill maher and chris cuomo in a
conversation about transgender came out
if you've not seen it i highly recommend
you know you go watch a jack it's
absolutely by the way you're not going
to find it on cnn's youtube channel you
got to find it on somebody else's
youtube channel i'll text at you
afterwards it's like 34 minutes i have
the link it's a must watch you made a
very good argument to him um but what do
you say to navy seal that's now you know
somebody came out a couple years ago
talking about the fact that they're
transgender former navy seal i don't
know if you saw that story or not
uh uh if you followed it kristen beck i
think it's the name of the individual
that now is uh transgender
do you think how do you think the seal
cream of the crop at that level special
ops type of guys delta you know navy
seal how do you think they should treat
uh
training women as well as transgender
uh uh in regards to their units
see uh well the women want to find a lot
more about than the transgender one
because it's uh the transgender one i'm
just not quite sure what it means what
and how we
anyway i'm not
i'm not quite prepared to think that
through from because any from women
coming in wanting to be men men coming
in one of the women i've just there's a
lot to unpack there um but when it comes
to
the females in combat ground forces
particularly special operations um so
they've been on the front lines with us
from the beginning of the war on um so
they've been right there they haven't
been entering rooms and getting shot in
the face that sort of thing but they've
been right there with us in these
supporting roles and supporting role
sounds um you know like it's not the
right word because they are right there
um and for me like i grew up
as a lot of people did
uh
opening doors you're taught to open the
door for for a female you're open you're
taught to stand up offer your seat to
a lady that gets on a bus or a train or
something like that stand up one woman
enters the room um treat them with this
respect uh uh but almost you know you're
putting them on this
is it's this respect and it's putting
those pedestal type things so for me
there's no possible way that as a combat
leader i would be able to treat a female
exactly the same as i would one of the
guys
i just it's not i'm not programmed that
way uh for whatever reason i'm
programmed to protect females that's how
i was raised and that's in my dna i
don't think i need to be raised that way
i think it's just innate in us as humans
uh to protect those who are going to
carry on and make sure that that that
our bloodlines and our species continue
to move forward after we're dead and
that's why we go forward and uh and gets
you get cut up and killed in combat all
the time protecting them
so for me it would be very difficult to
treat them exactly the same way as i
would uh a guy who's a
a dude that's just how it is
now the other side of that is you know
you have daughters and you want them to
have the same opportunities as and
freedoms that uh that their male
counterparts have so there's a
definitely a
discongruence there in that in that line
of thought but once again it's just very
natural to protect the females and the
species whether they want to be or not
you know that's uh
sorry uh and that's why i'm glad i got
out before that became something i had
to deal with once again i can deal with
that in the pages of the novels because
maybe this next generation isn't going
to be maybe it's going to be like
starship troopers and they're going to
treat each other just the same it
doesn't matter if you're a female uh or
you're a male you're both you're running
that you're running into that uh
those machine gun bullets just the same
it doesn't it doesn't matter maybe we're
getting to that a point and is that a
good thing i don't know you might want
to protect that person that's going to
make sure that the bloodline continues
um we have for most of human history and
for most of human history
you had to be good at a couple of things
you had to be a good hunter and you had
to be a good fighter
and only very very recently have we've
been able to outsource both of those
things by uh calling 911 and going down
to the local grocery store to get food
uh that is of the smallest portion of
human history
so i think in all of us there is that
natural tendency to still be a protector
to still be a provider
i think it's in there it's getting bred
out of us though by once again by every
single input that we have uh almost
almost every single input that we have
from big tech big government big media
um legacy media uh they're all preaching
something different and hey i don't know
if the lights go out tomorrow and all of
a sudden we're back to what we've been
for most of the human history having to
be good at those things maybe that
dynamic changes a little bit maybe we're
not so concerned about uh quality of uh
equity and outcomes and all those sorts
of things that are really uh
just undermining the very foundations of
this country so
you know we'll see
i i you know i asked that question
because
um you know part of me is like okay one
uh
do are there a lot of women that want to
be navy seals because if there is well
great that's fantastic that's one
question second thing
is the media try to
you know pin them against each other
like i don't know if you saw an article
that came out from variety yesterday
and uh uh uh about gamers did you see
that article yesterday about gamers or
no
uh uh
where you know the top 300 gamers
tournament that's going on right now not
a single one of them is uh women why is
that why is it such a
sexist space that gamers are
not uh women now that's a little bit of
a weird uh uh uh article to do so
question i would ask is how many women
want to be gamers do you want to be a
gamer do you want to be in that space if
you do great
do you really want to sit there playing
10 hours of video games to compete there
fantastic if that's your world go do it
so navy seal do you want to go be a navy
seal yes i do great so if that's the
case
does it work does it make the
environment uncomfortable are guys not
going to be acting like themselves
because you know when guys are with guys
you tell us certain jokes the moment you
put somebody else there maybe you get
uncomfortable
you know um
and then the other part is
i got friends that are more
uh
metro and uh uh what do you call it they
have more estrogen than testosterone and
i have female friends that have more
testosterone than estrogen you ever met
some of your friends where you're like
oh my gosh you dude
you know you're one chromosome away from
being married you know and and then you
have a friend that they're one
chromosome away from being you know
bobby you know where it's like the level
of toughness like ronda rousey can
probably whoop 90 percent of guys asses
if she fights them what if she wants to
be a navy seal would it would it be good
for to be an abco i don't know
uh so i wonder how much of it is
mainstream media just needs another
story to pin people against each other
so we talk about it versus how much of
it is actual demand for women wanting to
be navy seals
yeah i always go back to hey does it
make us a more effective effect no
matter what it is doesn't have to be
women wanting to be seals it can be it
could be anything
and hey does this make us a more
effective and efficient fighting force
and if the answer is no
then don't do it military
focus on winning wars focus on being
prepared for war that is why you exist
that's why you get these insane budgets
um and
so so that's the question so for me it
doesn't really come down to
a
quality
and equity and making sure everyone but
no it's uh it comes down to does this
make us a more effective and efficient
fighting force uh and for me
uh
you know but yes me maybe it's just uh
maybe i'm the i'm the neanderthal and uh
and and uh
yeah and maybe maybe having a female in
the platoon space is a good thing for
all the guys in there
i don't know i've seen what happens when
a female walks into a tactical
operations center overseas uh it changes
the dynamic and not in a good way no and
it's a sad it's i hate to say that but
it's the truth and today you can't
really you know you tell them to tell
the truth you get you get
shot down they get canceled but uh i
mean it does change the dynamic yeah you
guys are guys you know
it totally changes the dynamics
you know hey
sorry i interviewed a lot of comedians
and the one thing i can tell you about
comedians is
most comedians i'm not saying all of
them but most comedians
lived a very tough life
they had a dad who has a temper he used
to drink hit him or mom left or
some shitty situation that they had
right where they become comedians so why
because you know their savior was
laughing at stuff right so dude the only
way i can my medicine is let me make
people laugh let me make myself laugh
because i have to go home and see my dad
beat my mom up or my dad beat me up and
my brother up and i just it's my only
way to release right it's a very common
trend with many comedians
military
you know when you're in that kind of a
pressure type of an environment
i mean sarcasm jokes laughter shots you
know not shots like shots like taking
shots at each other
condescending witty it almost seemed
like that was the medicine to
overcome the
whatever
situation you're in and it's tough to
explain uh you explain it to a regular
person they'll say well that's not the
right way to
deal with people and that's just not how
you're supposed to treat people and
michael jordan said in his uh uh
documentary the last dance there's a
scene in the last dance where he says i
remember when i was a kid or my brother
i think his name is adrian we're playing
basketball and he says michael you just
go out there you're like a kid you don't
know what you're doing let us men here
go build something and jordan explains
he says when i'm going he says you know
someone you're going through it it's so
hard because you're questioning yourself
as a manhood he says but that's exactly
what made me tough to be able to go and
compete the way i did in the military
you can't describe that to the average
person that's living in a regular la la
land versus what it is in the military
but again like you said maybe we are
neanderthals you know you from utah me
middle eastern from florida i don't know
i don't know i don't know what's gonna
happen anyways jack i really enjoyed
this uh uh what we're gonna do is we're
gonna put the link below to all your
books uh folks every one of his books
has over 7000 reviews and so you pick
and choose which one you want to do the
number one bestseller was devil's hand
we'll put the link below for you guys to
go pick it up and uh looking forward to
seeing your next book coming up jack
with that being said appreciate you for
making the time for being a guest on
valuetainment oh man thank you so much
for having me on and there you know
there's one thing that we talked about
earlier that kind of feeds in and i
heard larry ellison talk about it in an
interview and i've been very fortunate
to spend some some time with him and he
said i had all the disadvantages
necessary for success
and i love that because you have so many
people complaining uh especially your
children everybody that has children
will know uh your kids complain about a
lot of things but uh you know have to to
say that to identify hey i had all the
disadvantages necessary for success i
just i just love that and uh to me it
speaks to you know this speaks to what
this country allows you to go out and do
and create and invent and crush so um so
yeah that's just fantastic i think i'm
with you buddy well uh i'm glad that
we're still living in the greatest
country in the world and there's people
like you that want to keep it that way
so appreciate your courage man truly
thank you
thank you so much you take care take
care buddy bye-bye i hope you enjoyed
this as much as i did if you did give it
a thumbs up and subscribe i got two
videos i want you to watch one of them
is mike ritlin
former navy seal who wasn't as
diplomatic about his answers with women
being navy seals here's what he had to
say about it the other one is probably
one of my favorite interviews in regards
to a sniper from uk who has the world
record right the longest shot ever in
the world as a sniper with 80 confirmed
kills if you've never seen that one
click over here absolutely fascinating
interview having said that have a great
one everybody take care bye